Oui, il a bien dit ça.
Oui, il a aussi dit ça !
Mais vous ne devriez pas être surpris, parce
que Platon avait prédit l'élection de Trump.
Vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale,
la chaîne qui parle du meilleur de la pensée
sans vous prendre la tête.
Bonjour, je suis Romain, le créateur du site
1000 idées de culture générale et coauteur
du manuel du même nom.
Pour cette vidéo, je précise que mon but
n’est pas d’exprimer une opinion politique,
mais simplement d’éclairer, dans la mesure
du possible, une idée importante par une
situation contemporaine.
Ainsi, pour vous expliquer pourquoi il était
en fait prévisible, malgré l’incrédulité
générale, que Trump soit élu président
des États-Unis, je vais m’appuyer sur la
critique de la démocratie de Platon.
Platon, si vous ne le connaissez pas encore,
c’est probablement le deuxième philosophe
le plus connu de tous, après Socrate, qui
était son maître.
D’ailleurs, dans son livre La République,
comme dans beaucoup d’autres, il fait parler
Socrate, en l'occurence pour réfléchir au
meilleur régime politique possible.
Et pour lui, ça n’est certainement pas
la démocratie, parce que ce régime aboutit
à donner le pouvoir à des hommes comme Trump.
La première raison pour laquelle Trump devait
gagner selon Platon, c’est que la démocratie
est le régime qui favorise les sophistes.
Trump, vous l’avez remarqué, est un homme
politique très particulier dans la mesure
où il s’exprime différemment des autres.
Il paraît plus direct, plus franc, il choque
et il utilise son éloquence pour défendre
des positions controversées.
Pour Platon, c’est un peu ça un sophiste,
c’est un orateur qui met son talent au service
de l’opinion et du préjugé.
Plus généralement, les sophistes constituaient
une école philosophique dont la doctrine
était fondée sur la seule recherche du succès
grâce à l’art de convaincre et de séduire.
De ce point de vue-là, Trump s’est signalé
par une véritable efficacité oratoire, avec
des innovations comme le fait d’associer
systématiquement le nom de son adversaire
à l’adjectif « crooked » qui signifie
« corrompue ».
Ce qui fait plus fondamentalement que le discours
du sophiste est efficace en démocratie, c’est
qu’il n’a que faire de la vérité.
La seule chose qui compte pour lui, c’est
de convaincre l’interlocuteur.
Dès lors, il lui suffit de dire au peuple
ce qu’il a envie d’entendre d’une manière
qui lui plaise.
Et c’est un peu ce qu’a fait Trump avec
son positionnement anti-élites et en reprenant
systématiquement les thèmes et les idées
qui n’ont pas bonne presse.
Pour Platon, c’est là typiquement le genre
de discours qui plaît au peuple.
Le sophiste est en fait un démagogue qui
flatte les plus bas instincts du peuple.
On va voir pourquoi ça marche si bien.
La deuxième raison pour laquelle Trump devait
gagner, c’est que le peuple est bête.
Eh oui, il n’y va pas par quatre chemins,
Platon, parce qu’il a écrit à une époque
où la démocratie n’était pas considérée
comme le régime idéal, contrairement à
aujourd’hui.
Dans la perspective du philosophe, les électeurs
qui ont élu le sophiste Trump sont bêtes.
Et cette bêtise, elle se caractérise plus
précisément par deux choses.
C’est tout d’abord de l’ignorance.
La bêtise du peuple, c’est aussi une tendance
à simplifier les problèmes en en supprimant
les nuances.
Pour Platon, cette bêtise est le symptôme
de l’irrationalité du peuple.
En clair, la masse populaire est incapable
d’analyser les problèmes de manière claire,
logique et réaliste ; sa compréhension se
limite aux apparences et elle est noyée dans
les passions, comme la jalousie ou la haine.
Le philosophe va d’ailleurs jusqu’à comparer
la foule démocratique à un « gros animal
» dont la dangerosité fait passer les désirs
pour des nécessités vraies aux yeux de son
soigneur.
Mais si le peuple est si bête, qui devrait
gouverner ?
Pour Platon, ce sont les philosophes, car
ils sont les seuls à posséder la connaissance
du vrai et l’expérience nécessaires pour
diriger.
Ces deux qualités sont l’apanage du philosophe
armé de sa raison.
Du coup, si un sophiste comme Trump parvient
au pouvoir, eh bien ça risque de mal se passer
d’après Platon.
La troisième raison pour laquelle Platon
avait prédit l’élection de Trump, c’est
que la démocratie engendre le désordre.
Plus les vices de ce régime s’épanouissent,
plus on se rapproche de la situation où de
parfaits sophistes comme Trump peuvent arriver
au pouvoir.
Le premier stigmate de cette évolution, c’est
la division.
Vous n’ignorez pas que l’Amérique de
Trump est profondément divisée, au moins
entre ses partisans et ses détracteurs.
Alors que les premiers le voient comme le
président qui va les protéger des abus des
élites, les seconds le perçoivent comme
une grave menace pour diverses libertés et
droits fondamentaux.
Pour Platon, le risque était plus précisément
que le démagogue au pouvoir oppresse l’élite
à tel point que celle-ci se désolidarise
du peuple, ne se sente plus responsable à
son égard et le laisse faire n’importe
quoi.
Or, la justice requiert que ces deux composantes
de la société vivent en bonne harmonie.
En effet, la division engendre inévitablement
du désordre.
La personnalité de Trump est si clivante
qu’elle crée du trouble jusque dans la
conduite des affaires.
On peut citer à ce propos les soupçons de
tricherie à l’élection, les oppositions
judiciaires et administratives aux premières
mesures
de Trump, ou encore sa difficulté à constituer
ses équipes.
Platon nous avait prévenu que la démocratie
devient alors un « bazar de constitutions
» où chacun se sent libre de faire ce qu’il
entend : il obéit s’il le veut bien, fait
la guerre si l’envie lui prend, etc.
Et pour le philosophe, comme la démocratie
décuple les discordes et les dissensions,
le peuple en arrive en dernière instance
à confier le pouvoir à un tyran pour empêcher
la guerre civile.
Le risque, pour Platon, c’est que le vice
et l’excès du régime démocratique conduisent
à la sortie de la démocratie, à une violente
réaction qui tienne le peuple en servitude.
Mais bon on en est pas encore là.
En résumé, Platon avait prédit l’élection
de Trump parce qu’il nous avait prévenu
que la démocratie est un régime qui aboutit
à donner le pouvoir à des démagogues susceptibles
de diviser la société et de semer le désordre.
Alors bien sûr, comme d’habitude, la relation
que j’ai établie a des limites.
Par exemple, Trump n’est pas forcément
beaucoup plus un sophiste que les autres hommes
politiques, même s’en distingue beaucoup
; le choix de voter pour Trump peut très
bien être rationnel, et les extraits que
j’ai choisis sont bien sûr des caricatures
vouées à faire sourire ; enfin, il est très
exagéré de dire que le désordre règne
aux États-Unis au cours des débuts de Trump,
même si le système étatique semble moins
stable que les années précédentes.
L’intérêt de l’idée de Platon, c’est
qu’elle met en évidence la tension entre
la vérité et la liberté comme fondements
de la légitimité du pouvoir.
Les élites platoniciennes veulent gouverner
au nom de la vérité qu’elles détiennent,
mais le peuple doute de cette vérité et
préfère donc maîtriser lui-même son propre
destin, c’est-à-dire être libre.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la prochaine.
Pour lire ma synthèse de l’idée de Platon
sur le site 1000 idées de culture générale,
voire pour pour lire l'ouvrage La République
directement, les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Enfin, pour recevoir les dernières idées
de culture générale synthétisées dans
le format le plus clair possible, vous pouvez
vous inscrire à la newsletter en laissant
votre adresse e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.